chris is in omaha nebraska hi chris
welcome to the ramsey show
gentlemen how you doing today thanks for
having me absolutely how can we help
so a couple years ago we had our second
child
and during all the prenatal appointments
and everything
um some things got screwed up um on
their end
and we got billed for a fourteen
hundred dollar doctor bill um
and we went round and round between
insurance and the doctor
that apparently never got settled
because we just got hit
with uh collections agency
for that fourteen hundred um
i talked to the lady at collections
tried to negotiate for a lower amount
or something and she said no we're not
that kind of collections you have to pay
at all
so just looking looking for some
guidance here
i'm not that kind of girl yes you are
[Laughter]
yes you are that kind of girl
oh my gosh what about what a load of
crap okay
so uh have you gone back to the dock yet
um well actually we we've since
moved that was when we lived i don't
care it's been a couple years we got
phones there
okay you hadn't called the doctor's
office yet and go hey
butts i'm getting a bill from you people
that was part of the rigmarole between
you know hey why isn't insurance
covering this and
why are we getting a bill that was part
of the whole rigmarole a couple of years
ago okay well let me let me
let me kind of let's lay a foundation
here all right sometimes
including you people get the idea that
because
insurance is supposed to pay something i
don't legally owe it
you do so you have a bill with a doctor
for x number of thousands and thousands
of dollars and you
owe 100 of that bill you are liable for
it
you're the consumer of that service you
owe the bill you however purchased from
a third party
insurance that is supposed to pay some
of the doctor bill
that you owe if they do not pay it it
does not remove you from liability
you owe the doctor bill and so since
insurance has not paid this if it's a
valid bill you owe it now what you do
can do is go back and shoot through
their butt and go why didn't you people
run this through insurance properly
which you've already done once why
didn't they fix it then
i'm asking you why didn't they fix it
then oh gotcha
so they said well we did run it through
insurance properly but insurance didn't
get the referral
and the right paperwork in time so that
insurance said well we can't backdate it
so you know we're not paying so the
doctor did not submit it to the
insurance company properly
uh yes okay then i'm chewing their butt
and saying guys you need to write this
off instead of holding me to it
because you didn't do your job
okay and that's the conversation you
should have had back then and now you
get to have now
and they get to pull it back out of
collections uh or
you get on the dock and you finally go
okay because but you need to start with
the premise chris that you do owe the
money
legally sure and you can't go before the
judge if you get sued and go well
insurance is supposed to pay it
because he's just going to laugh and go
insurance saying my problem dude you
have a contract with the doctor the
contract is broken because you didn't
pay the bill
now now however the doctor's office
part of the service they're supposed to
provide you
as well as to labor and delivery is to
take care of insurance paperwork and the
proper order
that way they get their freaking money
uh and since they didn't
do that i would challenge them that this
is their problem it's not legally their
problem it's morally and business-wise
their problem
does that make sense yes sir yeah
legally
if they don't file any paperwork they
can come after you for
all of the bill they can just throw up
their hands and go
we're totally incompetent we're not
filing nothing
and we're gonna own chris okay
they can do that legally but it's a it's
a horrible way to run a doctor's office
it's a pr bad practice management and
you're going to tell everybody you know
not to go over your baby over there so
uh yeah i'm going to call the office
administrator and have a discussion with
them i mean calmly and kindly but firmly
go guys this is on you it was your lack
of competence
and you should not be trying to bill us
for something as you didn't file the
insurance paperwork part of the service
you provide
as well as labor and delivery is to take
care of filing the prop paperwork in
proper and timely manner and you did not
do that
and now you turn it over to collections
and these bozos who says she's not a
girl like that and she is coming after
me it's ridiculous
and so that's how you handle it now at
the end of the day you're going to end
up settling this with the doctor's
office hopefully for pennies on the
dollar
so get ready to write a 500 check part
of that's on you because you didn't
settle this back when it was hot
when the deal's hot when there's a
problem you can't just walk away and go
i wish it was okay
it's always going to come out of the
closet later and get you i'm
right in the middle of a dealing with
this exact same thing
and with the bill and um it's
frustrating
and you got to continue to make that
phone call well here's a funny one
so sharon was at rachel's uh first book
tour
party launch party and i'm in the truck
heading to the airport and
i get a call and sharon passed out and
so
she just had a blood iron or something i
mean it's five years ago
and lobe iron or something and was
excited and everything or whatever and
and so they
load her up in an ambulance and take her
to the dock and i go down the emergency
room
she's okay she's embarrassed she's like
i'm all right am i right am i right
okay so i never thought anything else
about it again so i start getting these
phone calls
for collection for a bill in collections
me
somebody's calling me and i'm going well
you got this is this is absolute bull
crap there's no possible way i have a
bill out in collection
that's just ridiculous and so i'm just
like i'm just hanging up on the guy you
know
whatever i'm talking to him and so
finally
the guy just they just they're wearing
me out and so i turned it over i gave it
to our attorney
our staff legal counsel here i said hey
man call these guys and straighten this
out tell them i'm
getting ready own me a little collection
agency because i obviously do not owe
an outstanding bill that's gone to
collections this is ridiculous
well he digs around fight figure out
it's an ambulance bill
oh goodness i did owe the money uh
there's a 400
ambulance bill and i never got a bill
okay they never billed me they
just jumped it in collections and then
this little idiot's calling me with a
headset on you know
and this kind of stuff so i i did owe
the bill i ended up having to pay it but
but uh i'm just ignoring the guy just
and i wasn't cause i i just thought it
was bogus i'm the i'm in the
you cannot ignore it i i even tried it
you cannot ignore it it comes back chris
and then they start tacking fees on it
well they're trying yeah that didn't
work either
i i looked at them i went to the
emergency room on christmas day
with a poison ivy uh it's a whole other
story no i don't want nobody you don't
worry but listen how do you get poison
ivy in the middle winner no don't tell
me i'm not gonna tell you
um it's a way only delaney can yeah but
i looked him in the eye and said if i
pay you cash
can we shake hands walk out and their
eyes lit up you're gonna pay us cash in
a rural er
absolutely what you got and i told them
a number
and i said dave i looked at this this
human being it was during cove through
the
through an ipad and i said you promised
me i don't you need more money we're
gonna shake hands and walk out of here
and she said absolutely i'm asking you
one more time and you're recording this
right she said yep
we shook hands it was good it was an
obnoxious amount of money but it's my
own fault for getting poison ivy in
december that's what i get i went home
got it i got a bill and it was a big one
a big bill and i said what in the world
they said well that was for the hospital
the doctor has a different charge and i
said that's like me going to burger king
and getting a number
two combo and then three months later
the fry guy
sends me a bill at my house that's part
of the package
i thought the doctor was the key part of
the emergency room service
evidently not and so now i've got this
do i want to lose sleep and go to war
over 200 bucks
or nope what kind of i do dave
well yeah i do i know you you want to
but i'm just saying do you want to
so the uh i get the want to part but the
uh
here's the thing it turns out that you
can be in the medical industry and be
horrible at business practices
and math why why apparently
i mean because they've survived that way
for decades now i mean
every one of you listening out there has
a horror story with some stupid butt
medical bill
everybody does i mean i actually was
auditing
a customer who's about to go bankrupt
one time and they got charged
46 dollars a piece for advil
forty six dollars per tablet
uh you can't make this crap i love
america